vous êtes sans domicile fixe depuis deux
ans à perpignan alors vous allez en ce
moment très provisoirement un toit
au-dessus de votre tête si on peut
appeler ça un toit est ce que c'est un
studio proche de l'un pas presque
insalubre quoi c'est ça tout à fait et
vous êtes vous courez le risque de le
perdre
d'un jour à l'autre à tout moment le
problème c'est que bon mois tout allait
bien pour moi il paie j'ai eu un
incident de parcours comme tout le monde
ce qui peut arriver à tout le monde
je me suis retrouvé sdf et
et les coïncidences parcours l'incident
de parcours c'est que j'ai fait
confiance à des personnes qui fallait
pas et je me suis retrouvé sécher
personnes là qui m'ont viré en plein
confinement et je me suis retrouvé à la
rue en plein confinement ce qui a été
très difficile pour moi parce que je
n'avais pas les du tout l'habitude de
vivre comme ça c'était la première fois
que je devenais sdf
donc ça m'a mis un grand choc et puis en
arrivant sur perpignan j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer une association magnifique
qui s'appelle au coeur de l'humanité 66
et j'ai la présidente flora avec la
vice-présidente fatou qui m'ont
énormément aidé et grâce à ces personnes
là aujourd'hui ben je ne suis plus on va
dire entre guillemets à la rue mais ça a
été un parcours très difficile et je ne
souhaite pas le revivre parce que c'est
vraiment pas facile et c'est dur pour
tout le monde et c'est vrai que c'est un
parcours pour moi ça a été une descente
aux enfers vraiment vraiment vraiment je
n'avais pas du tout l'habitude de
rencontrer des assistantes sociales ou
de rencontrer des gens qui sont là pour
travailler avec nous et heureusement que
j'ai eus ces deux personnes là fatou
avec flora qui montrait comment faire
qui m'ont beaucoup aidé sur le chemin
dans lequel je suis aujourd'hui et je
leur dois énormément à cette association
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je suis
bénévole dans des associations où je
distribue à manger le café
le petit déjeuner ont fait des dons
grâce aux donateurs et aux donatrices
qui nous donne pour cette association la
hauteur de l'humanité et ont fait de la
rue distribution pour tout le monde ça
veut dire que toutes les personnes qui
sont sdf ou en précarité ou qui ne
savent pas où aller ou même pour parler
pour discuter et ben au coeur de
l'humanité sont bienvenus et grâce à ces
gens là on en arrive à quand même faire
énormément de choses à faire avancer les
choses pour que les sdf et les gens qui
sont dans la précarité puisse avoir une
qualité de vie qui s'améliore et un
bien-être
on va dire aussi bien physiques mentales
pour pouvoir affronter les épreuves de
la vie mais quels sont les effets
particuliers que produisent les
confinements sur ces gens en détresse
comme les sdf
ils sont très très dur parce que quand
on vient pour chercher du travail et que
tout est fermé quand on vient pour faire
des papiers administratifs parce qu'on
n'a pas internet où on n'a pas les
moyens d'avoir internet
eh ben on ne peut plus rien faire donc
que ça soit pour on va dire bah pour
tout pour c'est ça ce sont les
difficultés d'ordre pratique de
pratiques qui sont évidemment énormes
mais est ce qu'il ya vraiment des
problèmes particuliers d'un point de vue
psychologique qu'est ce que ça produit
mais il ya aussi dans ce domaine parce
qu'on est dans l'isolément total
on n'ose pas en parler aux gens parce
qu'on a honte premièrement on se dit que
ça va pas m'arriver puis le jour où ça
nous arrive on n'a pas du tout envie
d'en parler donc on n'a pas envie d'en
parler on a envie de s'isoler on a envie
de rester seul parce que quelque part on
nous fait comprendre qu'on est exclu de
la société et c'est dur et pendant la
période dont confinement moi je les ai
vécus et je peux vous dire que ça n'a
pas été facile tous les jours ça a été
même très très dur est-ce que vous
visiez le plus mal pendant cette période
le plus mal ça a été bien le fait d'être
seul de se retrouver seul et qui est
personnes autour de nous quoi personne
pour pouvoir nous aider à part les
associations comme je vous ai dit
hauteur de l'humanité ou d'autres
associations qui prennent le relais
parce que
on va dire tout était fermé tout était
bloquée on n'avait aucune possibilité de
bouger et puis c'était très très dur
pour tout le monde donc les gens se
laisser aller il ne bougeait plus parce
qu'on pouvait plus bouger
moi personnellement j'ai essayé quand
même de chercher du travail de courir à
droite à gauche d'essayer de m'en sortir
j'ai subi des volumes des violences
policières des violences racistes
j'ai été traité comme un moins que rien
parce que je me suis retrouver sdf et ce
n'était pas le but du jeu quoi le but du
gc on essaye que je m'en sorte ou que
les personnes qui sont avec nous puis
s'en sortir aussi et on fait en sorte de
les aider même si on n'a rien et de voir
par exemple je peux pas citer des noms
non plus mes devoirs des grandes
enseignes soit disant qu'ils font de
l'humanitaire et qui vous rejeter qui
vous aide pas et qui vous renvoie
carrément de l'endroit après vous savez
plus du tout allait alors pendant le
confinement c'était intenable
impossible d'avoir des bons alimentaires
impossible d'avoir des vêtements
s'il fallait voir les assistantes
sociales pour qu'on puisse être aidés
c'était toujours décalé par rapport aux
que vides
et puis au bout d'un moment c'est qu'on
ne savait plus du tout quoi faire et
c'est vrai que ça a été très très très
très dur parce que pour moi pour toutes
les personnes qui étaient dans la
précarité sdf
c'était très très difficile avec une
solidarité entre sdf ou parfois s'il ya
une solide
il ya des violences entre goût il ya une
semaine il ya une solidarité entre sdf
mais comme a partout vous savez c'est
que c'est dur pour tout le monde donc il
ya des gens qui sont violents et au
figuré à des gens qui sont méchants il
ya des gens qui essayent d'avoir le
dessus sur les personnes les plus
faibles et qui s'en prennent justement à
des sdf hélas qui n'ont plus
l' envie de s'en sortir ces gens là bas
ils profitent de leurs fonds veut du mal
énormément de mal c'est un peu comme les
enfants mal placé mais là ce sont des
sdf mal placé docteur rolland bien vous
êtes psychiatre est ce que d'une manière
générale on n'a pas sous-estimer
justement les effets psychiatriques
alors particulièrement sur les
populations les plus vulnérables mais en
général c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas assez pris en compte
alors effectivement les a pas pris à ces
rencontres pour pour les raisons que je
vais essayer de vous expliquer les deux
raisons pour les deux histoires qu'on
vient d'entendre qu'ils sont vraiment
très très dur à entendre
ils correspondent à je dirais à des
fléaux de l'heure actuelle la première
c'est scène des enfants battus le
problème c'est que ça se place en milieu
fermé
la personne qui base son enfant n'a pas
conscience que c'est une entité
pathologique une maladie et l'enfant
n'osent pas en parler pour deux raisons
d'abord ils pensent ils imaginent
d'abord il se culpabiliser
s'il en parler et ils pensent parfois
que c'est comme ça qu'on lève donc il
n'ose pas en parler par la culpabilité
par la culpabiliser par la culpabilité
je pense qu'il faut absolument que l'on
soit attentif sur les signes extérieurs
qui sont souvent visibles sur l'enfant
un enfant qui est battu sa manière
mandat manière d'avoir la crème du
rapport à autrui quand on l'a proches
la manière dont il répond la manière
dont il se défend il a une sorte de
retrait c'est ainsi que des des marques
sur le corps qui sont parfois plus
facile qu'on imagine à dépister
sont une une solution qui peut nous
amener à répondre à ceux fixés pour les
enfants et dans le cas des sans abri les
enfants à poney sans abri d'abord que
deux à dire c'est que la cause le plat
principal qui est à la cause des enfants
qui est à la source des difficultés
psychologiques c'est que la maison le
lieu où on habite est le reflet le le
plus important de son identité et pour
être à l'aise pour savoir se diriger
dans la vie aller vers les aides
s'organisait pour les trouver il faut
déjà être comme on dit bien dans son
identité
donc je crois que il y a deux sortes dax
dans lesquels on doit aider les gens sdf
vous me direz si vous êtes d'accord
c'est leur donner une aide pour
retrouver
d'entités en excluant la notion de de
culpabilité de honte et deuxièmement
leur donner des coordonnées précises où
on peut leur trouver des aides et même
les accompagner dans la demande est
parce que parfois il existe des aides
mais on ne sait pas où ça se passe on
connaît pas les coordonnées et parfois
c'est un problème surtout si la honte
qui empêche de le faire c'est le travail
que vous essayez de faire mais quand
vous même vous étiez sans abri ce que
vous avez reçu la visite de d'une aide
sociale ou d'une et psychologiques n'ont
pas du tout fait aucune par rapport à ça
lorsque ça nous arrive c'est que déjà
c'est qu'on le prend pour nous et c'est
dur à vivre
comme l'a si bien dit le docteur c'est
vrai que la première identité qu'on a
c'est le fait de chez nous quand on a
grandi dans une maison avec une famille
normale avec des comportements normaux
c'est vrai que du jour au lendemain
qu'on se retrouve à la rue c'est pas
évident et ensuite c'est le travail qui
est de longue haleine qui est dur parce
qu'on n'est pas du tout aidé par les
mairies ou par l'état ou même par les
conseils régionaux les conseils
départementaux et les associations avec
qui je travaille ils ne reçoivent aucune
subvention d'état aucune aide ça veut
dire que tout ce qu'ils font ils le font
des fois avec leurs propres
investissements ou avec le don des
personnes qui donnent des vêtements ou
qui donnent de l'argent ou qui donnent
les produits d'hygiène et qui font en
sorte à ce que ça tourne et c'est vrai
que quand on n'est pas habitué à tout ça
et qu'on connaît pas c'est très très dur
et je rejoins le docteur où il dit que
c'est une vraie honte par rapport à ça
et c'est ce qu'on pense et au bout d'un
moment on commence à penser comme
les gens nous disent quand on vient par
exemple pour chercher du travail et
qu'on leur dit qu'on est sans domicile
fixe vous êtes sûr qu'on va jamais nous
rappeler où par exemple quand on vient
pour faire des choses on nous fait
comprendre que on sert à rien où on nous
met toujours exclu on nous met toujours
en dernier on veut pas nous donner notre
chance m'a regardé je suis sûr super
pignon je dois montre qu'à travailler je
demande que c'est à dire que le message
va passer ce seuil il espère aussi y'a
pas de soucis et j'ai pas peur de
travailler comme beaucoup de personnes
n'ont pas peur de travailler mais c'est
que j'ai l'impression qu'on nous
pardonne pas le fait qu'on ait eu un
incident de parcours et qui peut arriver
à tout le monde je pense et que par
rapport à ça on n'est pas du tout aidé
donc on nous dit d'aller voir des
assistantes sociales on nous dit d'aller
voir au tel organisme ou tel organisme
mais ses propres organismes là ils sont
vraiment en retard parce qu'il n'y a pas
de situation d'urgence
ça n'existe pas et c'est grâce aux
associations sur perpignan comme au
coeur de l'humanité 66 il ya une
personne ou si qui s'appelle une chimie
qui est photographe et qui fait des gros
reportage sur les gens en difficulté à
perpignan il ya un monsieur qui
s'appelle erkan qui est un rappeur une
personnalité connue qui s'investit de
lui-même de sa personne et qui donne
énormément de leur temps
si on n'aurait pas ces gens-là les
donateurs les donatrices ou les
associations pour pouvoir nous aider on
n'a personne à perpignan et monsieur qui
s'appelle aussi loué aliot qui est le
maire de perpignan front national ou et
ils écoutent cette émission ce soir il
est le bienvenu pour vous aider aussi
absolu et bien sûr message et à
destination de tout le monde maintenant
sans étiquette politique je suis désolé
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
avec monsieur aliot par rapport à pujols
ah mais moi je dis pas ça paie mon
allure il est élu on a eu un hiver le
dire sinon j'écoute qui qui sera là avec
eux mais justement ce que je veux vous
dire que c'est qu'avec monsieur a lieu
on a eu un dialogue au coeur de
l'humanité 66 sont partis à la mairie
l'ont rencontrée est normalement ils
vont faire des choses pour pouvoir
travailler en signer mais avec le
dialogue deux c'est mieux voilà avec
monsieur pu avec monsieur pujol par
exemple il n'y avait rien du tout un
qu'aucune communication et il ne voulait
pas parler aux associés aux endroits
nous appelait même pendant l'émission au
total
manou il souhaite un meilleur avenir à
base de vous tirer d'affaires
définitivement et merci de consacrer du
temps et de l'énergie
ces ingénieurs d'affaires ceux qui ont
été dans votre classement
vraiment